today on the matt well show harris and
biden have gone off to slay the
fictional dragon of voter suppression
meanwhile as they argue that it's racist
to require an id to vote more and more
democrat-run cities are requiring ids to
do literally everything else in life
also ted cruz questions the fbi about
its role in the january 6th riots their
answer i would argue confirm confirms
our worst suspicions and alec baldwin
continues to make himself the victim of
the fact that he shot and killed a woman
his case becomes even more outrageous
when you compare it to another recent
accidental shooting plus usa today runs
a piece arguing that we must
destigmatize pedophilia we'll discuss
that and much more today on the matt
walsh show
[Music]
you know a few decades ago and for most
of human history private citizens used
to be
that you know they were private what's
changed well the internet has changed
think about everything you've browsed
searched for watched or tweeted now
imagine all of that data being crawled
through collected and aggregated by
third parties
into a permanent public record your
record having your private life exposed
for others to see was once something
that only celebrities had to worry about
but in an era where everybody is online
everyone's a public figure everyone's
basically a celebrity at one level or
another
that's why to keep my data private when
i go online i turn to expressvpn every
time i turn xpressvpn on i'm given a
random ip address shared by other
expressvpn customers that makes it more
difficult for third parties to identify
me and harvest my data and the best part
is how easy expressvpn is to use no
matter what device you're on
whether it's a phone a laptop or smart
tv whatever it is all you have to do is
tap one button to get protected believe
me if it was complicated i would not be
able to do it i could do it so you can
too so if you uh like me believe that
your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one rated vpn
on the market visit
expressvpn.comwalsh and get three extra
months for free that's
expressvpn.comwalsh go to
expressvpn.comwalsh to learn more
well as you know this subject is always
difficult for me emotionally whenever i
hear democrats panicking over the attack
on voting rights it hits me right in the
heart it shakes me to the core
gets my hopes up because i very much
wish that there was an attack on voting
rights um i i think universal voting
rights is one of the worst ideas this
country has ever had
there are few things more worthy of
coming under attack than universal
voting rights
voting ought to be a privilege reserved
for those who are most competent and
qualified it's not a natural right
god did not imbue us all with some sort
of sacred entitlement to participate in
our national elections the bible
certainly makes no mention of any such
thing
so if it's not a natural right
which it emphatically is not
then it's a privilege that we grant and
it would be wise to consider a person's
basic qualifications before granting it
we are under no moral obligation
to allow hordes of stupid bewildered
clueless zombies to flood the voting
booth and cast their ballots in a state
of ignorance and confusion
helping to steer this giant ship of a
country right into one iceberg after
another
so that's my position which i state
often and without apology
i i am i'm against voting rights i don't
like them
um if it was a position shared by most
conservatives and by any significant
portion of elected republicans
democrats would be correct in claiming
that universal voting rights are under
assault
are at risk
but sadly it is all in the left-wing
imagination
i am you know a lone voice in the
wilderness on this issue
and in fact even if elected republicans
agreed with me
still the democrats would be wildly
incorrect about the nature of the attack
on voting rights because
nobody anywhere not even a reactionary
maniac like myself who actually is
opposed to universal voting rights
seeks to abolish those rights on the
basis of race
that's not a position held by anybody at
all anywhere in the whole country
literally not one single person has
suggested such a thing
and yet president biden and co-president
camille harris went down to georgia
yesterday to deliver a speech
railing against all of the fictional
racists and their fictional efforts to
prevent minorities and other oppressed
groups from voting
now they began the day's festivities by
laying a wreath at the crypt of martin
luther king jr
mlk could could but but look on in
horror from beyond as these two slimy
soulless reptiles
turn his grave into a campaign platform
and then when that was done co-president
kamala harris took to the podium to
repeat one of the left's favorite
mantras
this is not normal listen
the only normalcy anyone should accept
dr king said
is the normalcy of justice
and his words resonate today
over the past few years we have seen so
many anti-voter laws that there is a
danger
of becoming accustomed
to these laws
a danger
of adjusting to these laws as though
they are normal
danger
of being complacent
complicit
anti-voter laws are not new in our
nation
but we must not be deceived into
thinking they are normal
we must not be deceived
into thinking
a law that makes it more difficult for
students to vote is normal and i have
met with voters in georgia
i have heard your outrage about the
anti-voter law here
and how many voters will likely be kept
from voting
you know for a party that thinks your
four-year-old should go to the library
to listen to a drag queen read a book
about gender theory it's kind of jarring
to hear these people advocate for
normalcy
camilla also frets about
how many voters will be kept from voting
see this is another strange thing
we're told about all these voters across
the nation who've been kept from voting
because of the allegedly racist alleged
anti-voter laws allegedly passed by
republicans
and yet they've never provided
not ever not once
even one single real-life example of an
actual human being
who wanted to vote
and was legally eligible to vote
and yet was prevented from doing so
because of one of these so-called
anti-voter laws
i've been asking this for years show me
the person
just one person
who really wanted to vote and yet
somehow someway was unable to do it
show me this person i only want one
and if you do find that person the next
thing i'm going to want to know is their
iq
because voting is so unbelievably and
unreasonably easy
that you would have to have the
intelligence quotient of a c-sponge if
you can't figure out how to navigate the
process or in fact you would have to be
dumber than that
because there are plenty of intellectual
sea sponges in america and yet still all
of them
tragically unfortunately managed to vote
next joe biden took the stage
immediately he proves uh yet again
what a decent and kind old man he is by
claiming that all of his political
opponents are segregationists and
confederates
how do you want to be remembered
at consequential moments in history
they present a choice
do you want to be the sign the side of
dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide
to defend our elections to defend our
democracy
[Applause]
right about the cough there cut him off
right before he coughed he always gets
in
was like one cough per sentence this guy
uh just dying right in front of us our
president no big deal
many presidents and politicians have
myths you know that crop up around them
abe lincoln couldn't tell a lie
george washington and the cherry tree
donald trump and the p tape not all the
myths are family friendly but they've
all got myths but out of all these
legends none are more absurd more
divorced from reality
than the myth that joe biden is a decent
man
he is in fact very indecent he is a
nasty deceitful cold-blooded hobgoblin
who will defame and slander anyone who
fails to do what he wants he's also a
power-hungry narcissist so desperate to
claim the throne that he ran for
president even when he knew his mind and
body were failing
he was ready to plunge the whole country
into crisis just for a taste of power
so he's a deeply evil man
and speaking of being deceitful here he
is claiming that the georgia law the
georgia voting law makes it illegal
for people waiting in line to drink
water or eat food
longer lines at the poles
lines that can last for hours
you've seen it with your own eyes
people get tired they get hungry
when the bible teaches us to feed the
hungry and give water to the thirsty
the new georgia law actually makes it
illegal
think of this i mean
2020
and now 22 going into that election it
makes it illegal
to bring your neighbors
your fellow voters food or water
while they wait in line to vote
what in the hell heck are we talking
about
uh yeah i don't know that's a good
question joe
think about this
it's 2022 or no it's 20 20. going into
20. he said it's 2020 going into 2022.
so we skipped 20 21. i know it might
kind of feel like that and the 2020 was
two years long but actually wasn't now
what you just said there is uh well it's
not true at all first of all people
waiting in line in georgia
can be provided water
uh the poor deers they they can have
their water they're not gonna you know
die of thirst food can be provided as
well as long as it's not within 100 or
150 feet of of of the building
which means that people waiting in in
very long lines
can still eat okay because if it's a
very long line if you if you're waiting
you know we hear about people waiting
for hours supposedly well uh that means
that they're waiting far beyond 150 feet
from the building
and they can have their food
and also you can always just bring your
own food
if you think you might need it
so the entire thing is a non-issue but
this raises the question of why we even
need to provide full meals to people
waiting to vote
are we really a country of such pathetic
fat asses that we can't go a couple
hours without eating while we're waiting
to vote
is is this really a problem
who the hell needs to eat while they're
in line to vote
of all things
you can't just wait till you get home
fatty you know americans used to be
pioneers taking covered wagons across
vast expanses of wilderness towards
unknown destinations
and now we cry that our human rights are
violated if we can't eat a doughnut
while we vote
times have really changed i would say
as for biden's scriptural reference um
to begin with the exhortation to feed
the hungry was not meant to refer to
overweight people who are feeling a bit
peckish in line because they haven't had
a snack for the past 90 minutes that's
not what we mean
feed the hungry that's not what we're
talking about all right
but biden's concern for scripture is of
course highly selective because the
bible also says things like male and
female he created them
biden doesn't quite endorse that
sentiment these days and the bible
forbids murder especially the murder of
babies but again biden has different
ideas about that we see again that
nothing these people say can be taken
seriously
and that brings us to one final point
yesterday at around uh the time when
camila and joe were performing a
political tap dance routine on mlk's
mlk's grave the mayor of dc made an
announcement
joining many other large cities across
the nation like new york and los angeles
and many others
mayor bowser tweeted the following
remember that starting saturday you will
need these three things before heading
out
one proof of vaccination 12 years plus
two proof of vaccination and photo id 18
years plus three a mask
now think about this for a moment
we've been told repeatedly in panicked
and highly emotional tones
that it's a violation of an individual's
human rights to require an id to vote
why because allegedly some americans
many americans they say are simply
unable to obtain an id
give them four years to do it and that
they can't figure it out
they're just gonna sit there
helplessly crying for four years how do
i get an id someone help me
you know they don't know like they could
google it they could just call the dmv
google what's that i don't know how do i
know what number to call the dmv
and so they just sit there panicked for
four years they can't figure out how to
get id that's what we're told
the requirement is too onerous
to require an id is tantamount to
excluding these poor helpless people
from the polls and yet the same people
who make that argument
are now passing laws and ordinances
requiring an id and a vaccine card to do
literally everything in life
your fundamental participation in
society on any level
is now predicated on your ability to
produce both a photo identification and
a medical card
it does no good to claim that well this
is different because voting is a right
while say going to a restaurant is not a
right
really
because the civil rights act says
otherwise
the people who make this argument i'm
going to assume they would still say
that it's a violation of a person's
rights if they're prevented from
entering a restaurant on the basis of
say race
and at any rate
the point is that the argument against
voter id laws is predicated on the
obviously ridiculous idea
that it is unreasonable to expect people
to have ids
because there are people who just can't
they can't get them
yet again the people who claim this are
now ensuring that everyone has to have
ids anyway
to do anything anywhere all the time
can they not then also present the id at
the voting booth
is the simple act of reaching into your
pocket
to pull out the id
too much of a burden is that what we're
talking about
because we can't be talking about the
the difficulty of obtaining one
considering everyone's gonna have to
obtain these uh these these things
anyway
so are we concerned that the voters may
not have the strength
to reach into their pockets maybe that's
too strenuous after waiting for 82
minutes in line without a snack
it's ludicrous
i mean the whole thing
nothing these people say has any bearing
on reality at all
there is no attack on voting rights at
all
unfortunately
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know this has been a difficult
economic time for a lot of us thanks to
the branded administration and uh and
all the work that they've done
especially hard on businesses and that's
why one of them one of the many reasons
why it's so important these days to
support american companies i'll give you
one one of the best good ranchers good
ranchers is the exclusive meat company
of the daily wire and they help you get
american meat delivered they've got 100
american steakhouse quality meat and
it's all for an affordable price shop
good ranchers today to support american
made and put the small farm back on top
plus you can use my code walsh for 30
off that's the biggest first purchase
discount code good ranchers has ever
given out which means there has never
been a better time to buy good ranchers
also they're big supporters of daily
wire i've met the guys they're great
guys and um if you you know
here's the thing you're supporting a
great company you're supporting great
people
and uh american company but you're also
getting just a an awesome delicious
product at the same time so visit
goodranchers.com
walsh or use codewalls or checkout to
get 30 off
on any of their many boxes everything
they sell is truly top-notch and you
really have to try so visit
goodranchers.com to save 30 on your new
favorite steak start the year with good
ranchers american meat delivered
uh
need to eat while you're in line to vote
i'll never i will never get over that uh
i that will never stop being hilarious
to me all these stories of
uh you know that's another thing i
haven't seen i want to see
a story show me the evidence of people
starving to death
while waiting to vote okay like i want
to see the footage of that
it's just a it's just a bloodbath of
people lying there outside of the uh
elementary school gymnasium right
waiting to vote and they're just lying
there their rib cages are showing
they're starved to death
in the span of of 97 minutes
anyway
um
the good news though aside from that is
that i'm back now in my rightful chair
well actually the chair i'm sitting in
right now is not is not is not the x
chair um that's in my office
but i have it back anyway
and i thought about having someone wheel
my chair from my office to the studio
and then back to my office every single
day maybe i should still do that like we
have an intern now like that's something
that she could do
but anyway look i i know that some
people have have mocked me i saw the
comments
because i complained at length about my
missing chair only to discover live on
the air that it was sitting literally
five feet from me in the studio
and my wife complains about this kind of
thing all the time i'm dreading when she
she's always a few days behind listening
to the shows and uh
how dare she apparently she's got other
things going on in her life but
eventually she's gonna hear that segment
of me finding my chair that was sitting
right next to me
and she's and i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna have to deal with all the i
told you so because she's always
insisting that this is something that i
do or i lose things and i can't find
them even though they're right in front
of my face
like i'll shout to my wife hey do we
have any milk left
and she'll say we have we have six
gallons and you're looking right at them
currently right now
but you know what here's what it is
i'll tell you what it is i'm a visionary
okay i don't see what's in front of me i
see
beyond
i see what could be i try to explain
this to my wife um i don't see the milk
i'm not focused on the milk i don't see
the chair
i see a deeper truth
yes the chair was in the room with me
but but what is the room when you think
about it what is a chair
you know what i mean
i don't know what i mean i'm just a
[ __ ] i shouldn't be able to vote either
that's that's the honest truth of the
matter all right um we'll start here
jill uh jill sanborn is the fbi
executive assistant director she
appeared before a senate judiciary
committee hearing yesterday
to answer questions about january 6th
well
she appeared to be asked questions about
january 6th not necessarily to answer
them
and um
ted cruz uh
questioned her and uh
i think thoroughly redeemed himself from
the whole kerfuffle over january 6 then
calling it a terrorist attack
um this is actually as we've been
talking about the last couple of days
and people wanted to throw ted cruz
overboard because of of what he said and
how he characterized january 6th and as
i said that it's perfectly fair to
criticize him for that he deserves to be
criticized
we we should always be willing and eager
to criticize any politician when they
when they screw up
but uh i'm not ready to abandon the guy
because he gives us moments like this
that are really important so here he is
we'll go through some of these clips
um
sequentially here
questioning
jill sanborn
wanting to to find out did the fbi
have any kind of involvement with
january 6th at all
and you would think that if the answer
was no
it'd be really simple to say no
so let's listen to this
i want to turn to the fbi
how many fbi agents
or confidential informants actively
participated in the events of january
6th
sir i'm sure you can appreciate that i
can't go into the specifics of sources
and methods uh did any fbi agents or
confidential informants actively
participate in the events of january 6th
yesterday
sir i can't i can't answer that
did any fbi agents or confidential
informants commit crimes of violence on
january 6
6
i can't answer that sir
did any fbi agents or fbi informants
actively encourage and incite crimes of
violence on january 6th
sir i can't answer that
all right so she says that she can't
answer questions about sources of
methods but uh the problem is that he
didn't ask any questions about sources
and methods
he asked a very simple question were any
fbi agents
uh or fbi informants or anyone
affiliated with the fbi
were they involved in encouraging
inciting acts of you know rioting and
violence or anything on january 6th
and
they of course we get a no comment here
but i would say
that um
you know this is not like a court of law
with a civilian where
you've got a right to remain silent and
you know or or maybe you're being you're
being questioned about a crime by the
police
and you're in the interrogation room and
maybe you're refusing to say anything
even though you're totally innocent
because you realize the power dynamics
here you're at a disadvantage and you
whatever you say could be twisted
against you so you're not gonna say
anything until you have your lawyer
present that's just that's smart
but the same logic and rules do not
apply in this case
with a government with an agent of the
government representative of government
being asked a question like this
because if this is just a crazy like
it's it's either true or it isn't right
either the fbi was involved in some way
in inciting the events of january 6 or
they were not
and if they were not i cannot fathom why
they would refrain from telling us that
it's only confidential if they were
involved if they weren't involved in it
then there's nothing confidential
yeah i can pretty much guarantee you
that
if you were to uh get a nasa
spokesperson
on record in front of a
a camera and a microphone and ask them
uh sir
did did did did nasa fake the moon
landing
they're not going to say well i can't
comment on that uh we can't talk about
our sources and methods i'll tell you
something
that's one conspiracy theory of many
that i don't give any credibility to if
we got that answer then i'm going to
feel differently
but no i think what they would say is
that's crazy of course not
what's confidential it's like we didn't
we had nothing to do with it there's
nothing so there could have been
anything confidential that occurred
if this is um
totally baseless then the fbi not only
would say so but they would be more than
eager to say so
they would be saying so in front of
everybody because they are vindicating
themselves
and um and also all you have to do
is deny it
and for a lot of people that's going to
count as debunking that's going to be
decisive
now i'll admit that even if they did
deny it
that wouldn't necessarily be decisive
for me because it's possible they could
lie
but for most people and certainly for
the media that would be enough that's
all you have to do is just say no no we
didn't do it
the fact that they're not willing to say
that i think tells you something the
only reason i can think is that it's
true
and she didn't want to purge her herself
or be the one that gets thrown under the
bus for lying to congress about it so
instead she's going with the i can't
comment on that thing
all right moving on um
same line of questioning
ted cruz asks about this guy ray epps
who he'll explain ray ups but he was uh
this mysterious figure who was very
present on january 6th is on tape
breaking the law by encouraging rioting
and yet has for some reason not been
arrested
who is reyes
yep
i'm aware of the individual sir uh
i don't have the specific background to
him
well there are a lot of people who are
understandably very concerned about mr
epps
on the night of january 5th
2021 epps wandered around the crowd that
had gathered
and there's video out there of him
chanting tomorrow we need to get into
the capitol into the capitol
this was strange behavior so strange
that the crowd began chanting fed fed
fed fed fed fed
miss sandburn was rehabs a fed
yes sir i cannot answer that question
the next day the next day on january 6
mr epps is seen whispering to a person
and five seconds later five seconds
after he's whispering to a person that
same person begins to forcibly tear down
the barricades
did mr epps urge them to tear down the
barricades
sir
similar to the other answers i cannot
answer that
okay so she refuse says she knows who he
is but refuses to answer any questions
about him
once again if he's not working with the
fbi if he's if she has nothing to do
with this guy if her if her agency has
nothing to do with the guy
then i cannot
possibly understand why she wouldn't
just say
i don't i don't know anything about the
guy we have nothing to do with him
uh finally last clip here
there's the question of why this rayups
character was listed as wanted by the
fbi and then magically taken off the
list
though he was never actually arrested
shortly thereafter the fbi put out a
public post
listing seeking information on
individuals connected with violent
crimes on january 6 among those
individuals in the bottom there is mr
epps the fbi publicly asked for
information
identifying offering cash rewards
leading to information
leading for information leading to the
arrest this was posted and then sometime
later
magically
mr epps disappeared from the public
posting according to public records mr
epps has not been charged with anything
no one's exchang explained why a person
videoed urging people to go to the
capitol a person whose conduct was so
suspect the crowd believed he was a fed
would magically disappear from the list
of people the fbi
was looking at the sanborn a lot of
americans are concerned
that the federal government deliberately
encouraged illegal and violent conduct
on january six my question to you and
this is this is not an ordinary law
enforcement question this is a question
of a public accountability
did federal agents or those in service
of federal agent actively encourage
violent and criminal conduct on january
6th
not to my knowledge sir
so that's kind of interesting at the
very end after after
refusing to answer
on seven different occasions saying i
can't talk about i can't talk about it
finally the very end she says not to my
knowledge
so there's this change of tone midway a
slight change in tone
mid-stream
and speaking of changes of tone we
should mention that um after all this
question about ray epps and she didn't
want to talk about him she knows about
him doesn't want to talk about him can't
say anything about him
um even though he was encouraging people
to you know ted cruz says he's
encouraged people to go to the capitol
just to clarify he he is on video you
can find the video online
explicitly saying we need to go into the
capitol
shouting to the crowd the night before
we need to go into the capital we need
to invade the capital and that's what
caused the crowd to all start shouting
chanting fed fed fed and pointing at him
and then
he's there the next day he's whispering
to people and he's still encouraging
they do what he
said and this this guy doesn't end up
arrested
you know you're gonna you're gonna throw
a guy in prison for like stealing a
lectern or you find people wandering
around taking selfies and and
we're gonna arrest then but not the guy
one of the guys who came up with this
idea
is that not illegal
to explicitly encourage crowds
to violence it is
so with this one guy ray epps suddenly
um the uh
the powers that be have decided to be a
little bit more generous
that doesn't make a lot of sense and yet
even after this whole exchange where
the fbi doesn't want to talk about it
after the fact
some of the um
adam kinzinger and some of the other
people involved with the january 6th
committee they came out a few few hours
later and said oh actually you know what
we talked to that guy with the committee
and he told us that he's not involved
with the fbi
interesting how that works
i mean this ray epps dude
he's been known about online people have
been talking about him for months
we never heard anything about the
january 6 committee talking to him we
never heard anything about him
ex saying that he wasn't affiliated with
the fbi
the fbi representative herself
wouldn't talk about it and then after
this clip with cruz goes viral then adam
kinzinger
and his fellow hacks come out and say oh
this is a non-issue ah come on
see the denial has a lot less
credibility when it follows
that when there's when there's silence
silent silence
and then we get the denial
now we're asking questions
uh some more fireworks i want to play
this clip as well from a different
hearing this is a rand paul
versus fauci round eight i believe i
think they're at eight
go rounds now
rand paul calls fauci out for his
statement um that that he's he made it
on multiple occasions that disagreeing
with him fauci is disagreeing with the
science
dr falchi
the idea that a government official like
yourself would claim unilaterally
unilaterally to represent science that
any criticism of you would be considered
a criticism of science itself is quite
dangerous
central planning whether it be of the
economy or of science is risky because
of the fallibility of the planner it
would not be so catastrophic if the
planner were simply one physician in
peoria
then the mistakes would only affect that
physician's patients the people who
chose that position
but when the planner is a government
official like yourself who rules by
mandate the errors are compounded and
become much more harmful
a planner who believes he is the science
leads to an arrogance that justifies in
his mind using government resources to
smear
and to destroy the reputations of other
scientists who disagree with them in an
email exchange with dr collins you
conspire and i quote here directly from
the email
to create a quick and devastating
published takedown of three prominent
epidemiologists from harvard
oxford and stanford apparently there's a
lot of fringe epidemiologists at harvard
oxford and stanford and you quote in the
email that they or from dr collins and
you you agree that they are fringe
immediately there's this takedown effort
a published takedown though you know
doesn't exactly conjure up the image of
a dispassionate scientist
uh there's a certain futility to this
although it's good that uh rand paul is
holding him accountable because
almost nobody else is willing to do it
publicly
but there's just a futility to it
because uh this is an another huge
scandal the fact that
that fauci as represent as a government
employee
in in charge of the pandemic response
that has seen you know 800 000 plus
people die
i wonder if by the way if if fauci's
handling of the pandemic has been
successful
what does failure look like exactly
how would we know what failure looks
like how would we know how do we know
how to judge his performance
if 800 000 people dying is not
failure in a pandemic response then then
what is
eight million i mean what what is the
what's the cutoff
but anyway
um him conspiring with someone from the
nih to
to
put together a devastating takedown
of other scientists who are critic
critical of him personally
that's a major scandal that's one of
many major scandals involving fauci but
it just doesn't amount to anything
no accountability he'll continue to be
the highest paid
federal employee in history
um
but it is nonetheless
a shocking scandal
well not shocking in
terms of surprising but it is a serious
scandal
this is not science and you know it's
kind of unfortunate
that all of these sort of public uh
representatives of science
the people who actually claim to be
sole representatives of science it's
unfortunate that all of them are
partisan dishonest
despicable soulless hacks
because it does
after a while it gives people the wrong
impression about
science in general and what a real
scientist says fauci is not a real
scientist there are real scientists out
there
and it's a it's an admirable field to
enter into
and um
and i think that the actual scientific
mindset is also an admirable i mean if
you talk to it to a real scientist
they don't do this
they're not going to try to take you
down for critic for criticizing them
they actually
and there are scientists like this out
there it's just they're not on cable
news and they don't have jobs in the
government
but they encourage it they want to be
challenged
the last thing they would ever do is try
to take you down and punish you for
credit
they have their theories and their ideas
and they know that the only way to hone
those theories and ideas and to confirm
whether they're true or not
is to
put them up for scrutiny
and so they welcome that
they don't have this hubris and
arrogance
that's what real science is but we're
not seeing it we're just not we're not
seeing it publicly unfortunately all
right um here's a hilarious article in
the wall street journal by doug shone
and andrew stein
uh unintentionally hilarious
and
the headline is hillary clinton's 2024
election comeback
it says a perfect storm the democratic
party is making a once unfathomable
scenario plausible a political comeback
for hillary clinton in 2024
several circumstances have created a
leadership vacuum in the party which mrs
clinton viably could fill
she's already in an advantageous
position to become the 2024 democratic
nominee she's an experienced national
figure who is younger than mr biden and
can offer a different approach from the
disorganized and unpopular one the party
is currently taking
here's the funny part
if democrats lose control of congress
2022 mrs clinton can use the party's
loss as a basis to run for president
again enabling her to claim the title of
change candidates
hillary clinton will be the change kit
the the mummified remains of the clinton
machine will be the change candidate in
2024
now i
it to me it's not it's certainly not
unfathomable that she would run again
it's almost unfathomable that she
wouldn't as long as she's still alive
just like just like joe biden
she's desperate for power
she has lived her whole life in pursuit
of it
as far as she the only it's the only
thing she cares about and as far as she
can certain is concerned her life is a
waste
if she doesn't eventually obtain power
it's the you know and
in reality her life is a waste for a lot
of reasons but not for that
um so it wouldn't surprise me at all in
fact i would i would
expect it i mean i would i would give it
like an 80 chance
that um
unless she dies before that but even
that might not stop her she's gonna run
in 2024.
but here's here's an idea i mean there
are a lot of reasons to uh object to
hillary clinton as president certainly
you know you could probably name
probably about 200 of them off the top
of your head
but i've got i've got to ride this hobby
horse again here that
we don't we shouldn't need to get past
we could we could talk about all the
reasons
but we we shouldn't need to talk about
those reasons
because the only thing that we should
need to point out
is that hillary clinton is 74 years old
currently
and in 2024 she'll be 76.
she will turn 80 in office if she were
god forbid to win
um that is too old
that is way too old
even if she was the greatest potential
leader that this country would ever see
which she's very much on the opposite
end of that spectrum but even if she
were she's still too old
that is just too old
there are realities about the human
mortal condition
and one of them is that you cannot take
on a job like this in your mid to late
70s
we're seeing it happen we're seeing what
happens right now when we try that
we are watching our president die in
front of us
we have a guy running the country who
does not have his mental
faculties all in place
yeah
this is how pathetic it is that that she
would run
in 2024 as
the younger option she's the youth
option at 76
because somehow we've decided over the
last like eight years that only people
in their 70s can run for office a run
for president
i don't know why we've decided that
and it's not even like these 70 plus
year olds who are running are good
that's like it's nothing it's even
special about
it's too old
i'll tell you this right now i will not
support the nomination uh of course i'm
not going to be involved in
selecting the nominee for the democrat
party but in the republican party i will
not support the nomination of anybody
over the age of 75 ever
because it is too old and we are mortals
and that's just the reality
so would i apply this
to donald trump yes absolutely he's
going to be 78 years old we are seeing
what happens when a 78 year old is in
office and don't tell me oh trump is
different he's a spry 78 year old he's
not different he's mortal he's not
different
he's not
um
especially when
it's at least with the republicans there
is a 44 year old
effective talented charismatic
politician
waiting in the wings
how insane would we be
to say oh no i don't want the
the young charismatic um
sensational politician i i i'll go with
the 78 year old instead what
give me one good reason for that
this is crazy guys this is just totally
correct why can't we all agree on this i
mean that this is one thing it should be
bipartisan agreement
that we're not going to hire very
elderly people as president that's just
not a job that you can qualify for over
the age of 75.
blows my mind it just it just especially
when we're seeing what's happening right
now
we've experimented with it it's not
working out
and then there are people saying well
let's try it again
let's
let's try let's go from one 78 year old
to another and we'll just keep trying
and then if that doesn't work out we'll
just keep going to the nursing homes and
pulling people out until we find uh
someone who's you know
someone who's a pushing 80 years old who
can who can effectively do the job
without losing their mind in the process
all right uh one other quick clip i got
to play for you
alec baldwin
is uh still i guess defending himself i
don't know what you call this but here
he is ranting in his car i don't know
what this guy thinks he's doing ranting
in his car what kind of weirdo does that
um about the the shooting listen
the best way
the only way
we can
honor
the death of helena hutchins is to find
out the truth
that's what i'm working toward insisting
on demanding
um that the
organizations involved in this
investigation
uh do everything in their power
everything in their power to find out
what really happened that's all that
matters
the best way to honor
the death of helena hutchins is to find
out the truth
and um
any suggestion that we're not complying
myself and
any lawyers i'm working with or what
have you is a lie that's a lie we're
gonna as soon as we go through this
process then by all means we will comply
but um
but
i have no worries about that i have no
worries about that
that's all going to work itself out
regardless of what they say in these
right wing rack sheets and
people who are all about hate
um but setting aside all the
hate
setting aside all the january 6th of it
all
there it is
what
why did he hold up a pack of splenda
what
i never actually watched this clip so
i'm i'm uh
befuddled
so he held up a pack of splenda in which
he had drawn a smiley face
oh okay uh well
i guess he's innocent your honor
this i if he ever ends up in court i
guess this is what he could present
your honor your honor i present exhibit
a
splenda
i rest my case
well but that would require him to go to
court and be charged with the crime
which he has not been
instead he's making videos in his car
saying we have to figure out what
happened
we got to get to the bottom of this
i mean the hubris on this guy the
gumption
he he pointed a gun at someone and shot
them
and is now saying oh what hat we need to
figure out what happened i am dedicated
to getting to the bottom of this uh you
well you picked up a gun pointed at
someone who shot him in the face like
that's what that's what happened
i'm pretty sure that's it
it's actually not very complicated
but compare this here's the only point i
really wanted to make about this
um
alec baldwin accidentally shot and
killed someone
assuming that was accidental which i'm
you know we can't even be sure of that
but let's just assume that it was so he
pointed a gun at someone and shot them
has not been charged with any crime at
all
kim potter
uh
accidentally shot a dangerous violent
criminal in the course of trying to make
an arrest
and she is going to prison
so
what is that is that male is this an
example finally of male privilege well
no it's not male privilege
this is leftist privilege
this is uh being a rich famous celebrity
privilege
and those are you want to know what
privilege looks like like those are two
forms of actual privilege there's
ideological privilege
and then yeah there's the good
old-fashioned i'm rich and famous
privilege
that is real privilege and that is
enduring
we've always had that kind of privilege
in america it's that's always existed
and it will probably always exist um
into the future
that this dude is in his car waving
around packets of splenda a free man
while kim potter's going to prison for
who knows how many years
for what we know is an actual accidental
shooting where she didn't shoot some
some poor innocent woman who's a
cinematographer in hollywood
she shot a violent dangerous scumbag
whose death
is um is is
in many ways a benefit to his community
his community is better off without him
because he's a terrible awful violent
horrible horrifically evil person
she goes to prison not him okay let's
get to the comment section
[Music]
el paron says matt aren't you sad that
your ravens didn't make the playoffs
laughing emoji
you know what i'm not even sad i don't
care i don't this this is the the
the grief process i go through every
year
the ravens either don't make the
playoffs or they get knocked out
and uh but then you know what it is it's
a moment of clarity for me
when i realized that uh football uh
watching sports is a total waste of time
it's it's there's so many better things
you could be doing with your time
you know pick up a book and read it
spend time with your family
and i have this epiphany this
realization but then the season starts
again next year and uh it all it all
goes out the window
all right evan says matt
you use cults as an analogy for getting
pressured into cutting off your family
and loved ones you don't even need to go
that far every abusive girlfriend and
wife has three arrows in her quiver
isolate you from your friends isolate
you from your family and tell you that
your hobbies make her uncomfortable a
lot of the bureaucrats in washington are
women who are either single and
miserable or else brow beat their
passive husbands you could tell that
these women are the people writing the
coveted rules because they all seem to
come straight out of the crazy
ex-girlfriend playbook solid analysis
there
also kind of appropriate and timely
we're just talking about hillary clinton
and that's probably your prime example
of that
um
sweet baby gang for life says matt what
happened you read two bandworthy
comments and both escaped unscathed
what was the ban hammer in the shop or
something i've come to expect better
from you our aspiring cult leader well
you know what then fine then you're
banned sweet baby gang for life
you're you're revoked don't don't
criticize my methods i make these
decisions
not you
okay don't be like this is like when my
my daughter comes up to me and says
daddy you need to put uh you need to put
luke in time out here's what he did
there you don't decide that i'm the dad
you don't get to put people in time in
fact sometimes she won't even come to me
she'll just put her brothers in time out
and i'll walk into the room and i'll
finding them standing in a corner
so what are you guys doing but we were
putting time out by who
so
yeah this is an analogy because i the
sweet baby gang you were all like my my
children
but i'll be very quick to disown you
there's no loyalty here unfortunately
the loyalty goes one way that's how
cults work right
um and finally drew says january 6th and
matt's chair getting stolen one was the
most heinous attack on our very way of
life the other was a protest that got
out of control thank you drew
at least someone around here understands
the severity of the issue and what i
went through emotionally i appreciate
that
every time i go to the gas pump i am
shocked the new at
how expensive all the gas is
um
and i'm always looking for ways to save
some money the gas pump here's a great
way to do it it's the get upside app
have you gotten this app yet if you
haven't i don't know what you're waiting
for my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code walsh and
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back
don't pay full price the pump anymore
get cash back use it get upside just
download the app for free
and use promo code walsh to get up to 50
cents gallon a gallon cashback on your
first tank some people who drive a lot
are making two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back
and uh there's no catch the cash back is
added right to your account you can cash
out anytime
you just send the money to your bank
account paypal you can get a gift card
uh it's that easy all you got to do is
download the free getupside app and use
promo code walsh to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cashback on your first tank that
again is code walsh now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we cancel usa today for an
article published yesterday originally
titled what the public keeps getting
wrong about pedophilia
a link to the article was initially
posted to twitter along with a lengthy
thread explaining that pedophilia is
misunderstood and misrepresented
and uh the actual article was hidden
behind a paywall a short time later the
entire thread was deleted and a new
tweet was posted explaining quote a
previous thread did not include all
information and the story it was written
about is behind a paywall we made the
decision to delete the thread
they also apparently made the decision
to change the headline of the article
which is now titled the complicated
research behind pedophilia
now it's impossible to know what other
edits they may have made but they
removed the paywall and let's read a
little bit from the article as it now
stands
quote pedophilia is viewed as among the
most horrifying social ills but
scientists who study the sexual disorder
say it is also among the most
misunderstood
when most of the public thinks of
pedophilia they assume it's synonymous
with child sexual abuse a pervasive
social problem that has exploded to
crisis levels online
researchers who study pedophilia say the
term describes an attraction not an
action
and using it interchangeably with abuse
fuels misperceptions the american
psychiatric association's diagnostic
statistical manual of mental disorders
says that pedophilia is defined by quote
recurrent intense sexually arousing
fantasies sexual urges or behaviors
involving sexual activity with a
prepubescent child or children
scientists have in recent decades
improve their understanding of
pedophilia's causes prenatal and early
childhood risk factors as well as how
pedophiles can better control impulses
one of the most significant findings is
that scientists who study this disorder
say pedophilia is determined in the womb
though environmental factors may
influence whether someone acts on an
urge to abuse
all right the article then goes on to
favorably reference alan walker you may
remember walker as the creepy college
professor who advocates for
destigmatizing pedophilia walker's
affiliated with the prestasia foundation
uh which we've talked about on the show
he's appeared on there he or she i don't
know i can't remember which one on their
uh youtube channel and in interviews on
their their site
this is an organization that is several
levels beyond creepy and which is also
concerned with destigmatizing pedophilia
in fact if you go to prosthesis website
right now
the very first thing that pops up is a
quote safety guide for quote age play
if you're wondering what that is
prostagia explains that age play is
quote a form of role play in which at
least one of the participants adopts the
role or mindset of someone younger a
teenager a child or even a baby
so now you have some idea what we're
dealing with
back to the article in alan walker it
says
an academic at old dominion university
in norfolk virginia who's talked about
destigmatizing pedophilia and referred
to pedophiles as minor attracted people
resigned in november following the
outcry over the phrase alan walker
argued destigmatizing the attraction
would allow more people to seek help and
ultimately prevent child sexual abuse
there is growing support in the field
for walker's point of view while
clinical psychologist james cantor said
there's no treatment that can turn a
pedophile into a non-pedophile
pedophiles can be taught self-control in
compensatory strategies which he said is
more likely if they're under the care of
a professional he argues that pedophiles
need to be able to access therapy which
can be difficult since those afflicted
may be ashamed to seek help or worried
about being reported to the authorities
if they do
now um what can we say about all of this
after we finish vomiting into the
nearest trash can the most generous
possible interpretation
is that the author and those quoted in
the piece are drawing a distinction
between impulse and action
and advocating for strategies to help
prevent pedophiles from converting those
horrific impulses into action
now that sentiment alone by itself the
idea that we want to stop pedophiles
from acting on their desires is of
course uncontroversial everyone agrees
it's so obvious that it's not a point
that really needs to be made now it
could be a worthwhile discussion if
you're presenting actual tangible
prevention strategies
but all that the author of this piece
the author's name by the way is aaliyah
destiger
has to offer is therapy
that's a rather broad and useless
suggestion especially because it
requires us to have faith in the
psychological industry to handle the
issue effectively and appropriately and
i have no such faith
and that brings us to the larger problem
although there is a nugget of truth here
that there's a difference between desire
and action
and we want to prevent the actions
again obviously we want to prevent the
actions
but the very troubling and ultimately
fatal flaw
is that the morsel of common sense is
couched in a lot of pablum about
destigmatizing pedophilia
they're treated as a valid community
in a press community a victim class in
their own right
and much much emphasis is placed on the
on the claim
that pedophiles are are born with this
desire
now that latter point may also be true
in some cases it's possible
that something has gone wrong in the
brain of the pedophile and that at least
in some cases we can trace the problem
back to the womb
now that entirely removes the moral and
spiritual element once again
medicalizing the problem of human evil
which is a problem but um but it
wouldn't surprise me if there was some
sort of neurochemical facet to this
issue
fine
but the problem is that all of this
stuff
it's a community
they're stigmatized they're oppressed
their desires are natural quote-unquote
they're born with it
all of this has always been the pretense
for eventually normalizing and then
finally celebrating the act itself
now they're not doing it yet explicitly
even the nightmarish prostatia
foundation with its guide for pedophilic
sexual role play
isn't coming out and explicitly saying
that it's normal or good to rape
children
what we're witnessing now is the
groundwork
they're digging the foundation they're
laying the bricks for the hideous
building that they plan to construct
we've seen this process play out enough
times to know where it leads in fact
the idea that people who are born with
certain sexual desires should repress
them
refrain from acting on them that is
fundamentally incompatible with the
leftist worldview anyway
that's how we know that when it comes to
pedophilia normalization the current
point that we're at right now is but a
stage that they're passing through on
their way to the ultimate destination
now you might hope that this will be
different because most of the other
forms of perversion normalized by the
left have involved consenting adults of
various numbers and combinations
but children cannot consent obviously
perhaps the consent issue you might hope
will create a barrier
it will be like gandalf standing on the
bridge screaming you shall not pass this
is the one boundary that the fiery demon
of leftism cannot cross you might say
you might hope
but we know that the left is already
hard at work on this issue as well
on breaking down the idea of consent
because they tell us that children very
young children children as young as two
or three
can consent to all sorts of things
make all kinds of decisions even sexual
decisions
they can consent to change their gender
see you see how another foundation right
now is also being formed more bricks are
being laid
eventually the two construction project
projects will be connected
and within a few years i give it maybe
five years
the actual act of pedophilia will be
openly and explicitly defended
this usa today article is just one of
the opening salvos in that effort
and for that reason usa today is today
cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
vladowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host georgia hal for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire